[Musique]
des personnalités venues de toute la
france réunies à châteauroux pendant
deux jours la capitale de l'indre est
devenue celle des mobilités avec un
sujet qui s'invite désormais dans tous
les débats politiques pour ou contre les
transports publics gratuits
[Musique]
il est légitime
finalement que la collectivité que
l'intérêt public participe au prix du
billet et ça me fait réfléchir un peu
moins utilisé ma voiture est plus
prendre les transports en commun c'est
dangereux
inefficace et ça coûte la peau du dos
peut-être il faut sortir parfois des
logiques économiques pour inventer des
nouvelles solutions d'avenir
[Musique]
voir
à châteauroux tous les jours chucho
moussan goûts seront à l'arrêt de bus à
dix minutes de chez elle tous les matins
je viens c'est pour prendre les bis à
8h22 on va leur montrer
c'est un fait à
id châteauroux parce que dans 13 villes
mais des pistes à paris de fer social 68
euros par mois mais si c'est gratuit
elle n'est pas la seule à faire le
trajet jusqu'à des hommes dans la
banlieue de châteauroux le but vide
devant l'entreprise agir
une association d'insertion qui emploie
120 personnes en situation de grande
précarité
ici on tri des vêtements qui sont
destinés à la revente
brigitte la responsable recrute
principalement des femmes qui viennent
en bus ça leur permet aussi de pouvoir
devenir autonome
on a énormément aussi de femmes qui sont
monoparentales et effectivement ça ça
ça permet de pouvoir emmener les enfants
au centre aéré de les emmener à l'école
quand et ses transports est essentiel
pour notre région
châteauroux a été en 2001 la première
grande ville française à choisir la
gratuité des transports publics
à l'époque le bus n'avait pas la cote
21 voyages par an et par habitant contre
34 en moyenne pour les agglomérations de
même taille
la vente de billets représentait
seulement 14 % du coût annuel des
transports une sous fréquentation qui a
conduit la mairie de droite à prendre
cette mesure très social à l'époque
notre électorat traditionnel de droite
comme vous le qualifiez constitué de
chefs d'entreprise d'entrepreneurs lui
ce qu'il veut c'est que ces salariés
viennent à son entreprise aux heures
d'embauché et de kahler de dégauchis
puisse repartir et le plus facilement
possible donc sur la des bus gratuits
c'est mieux pour eux l'entreprise rio
l'an qui sous-traitent pour de grandes
marques de luxe a décidé d'ouvrir deux
nouveaux ateliers à châteauroux et le
critère a pesé lourd dans la balance
le temps moyen chez riot lancé 42
minutes pour se rendre du domicile où le
travail et c'est à peu près 41 km voilà
donc le transport en commun est d'autant
plus quand il est gratuit sa règle quand
même une grosse partie des
problématiques de budget et on a beau
coup de frein au recrutement aujourd'hui
parce que entre 180 et 200 euros c'est à
peu près ce que coûte le transport pour
un salarié aujourd'hui dans notre groupe
si on réduit de moitié voire de plus le
coût du transport c'est un vrai atout
pour le recrutement
pour les chauffeurs aussi le changement
a été de taille
châteauroux reste petit quand même donc
il fallait mettre un tig est donné on
perdrait vachement de temps et puis on a
un réseau quand même assez
assez ouverts à ces énergies et donc
voilà donc enfin le compte même les gens
qui viennent de la campagne arrive à
venir sur châteauroux pour pouvoir faire
ce qu'ils ont à faire
fini l'impression des billets mais aussi
les valideurs les contrôleurs et la
rémunération des points de vente une
économie de plus de 100000 euros par an
le tout sans licenciement selon keolis
le délégataire de service tous les
emplois ont été conservés personne n'a
été a été licencié ou s'est retrouvé
sans emploi à cause du passage à la
gratuité
aujourd'hui les contrôleurs d'hier
finalement deviez devenez les médiateurs
d'aujourd'hui non l'humanisation dans
les transports publics c'est un sujet et
châteauroux métropole nous l'a demandé
également
donc on n'a pas eu de difficulté de ce
côté là depuis le passage à la gratuité
la fréquentation totale a grimpé de plus
de 80% et continue à augmenter pour
transporter tout le monde
la ville a dû acheter l'an dernier des
bus articulés un tiers des déplacements
sont liés au travail et un tiers aux
achats dans les magasins ce qui
contribue aussi à maintenir le commerce
dans le centre ville
ce serait pas souhaitable en fait de
revenir en arrière ce serait une
régression ce serait reprendre du
pouvoir d'achat aux habitants ce serait
réduire la fréquentation parce qu'on
sait que si on remet les circuits de
transports urbains en payant il va avoir
une baisse de la fréquentation donc les
gens vont se reporter sur d'autres modes
de déplacement ou pour arrêter de se
déplacer et en termes de plus value
sociale des changes entre les
générations d'ailleurs parce que dans
les bus vous avez les jeunes vous avez
beaucoup plus âgées qui prennent le bus
pour voir du monde pour vivre ensemble
ce serait une régression qui clairement
n'est pas acceptable pour un homme
politique les uns mais en particulier à
châteauroux comme dans les autres villes
françaises
les transports sont financés par trois
sources différentes
comme l'expliquent le chercheur maxime
sûrs et spécialiste du transport gratuit
lorsqu'on passe à la gratuité en
transport on remet en question repose la
question du financement des transports
collectifs qui a assuré en partie par
les usagers faibles parti souvent en
partie par les entreprises via une taxe
le versement transport et en partie par
les subventions publiques et on voit que
globalement ce sont les subventions
publiques et le versement transport ces
dernières années qui finance la majorité
des du budget des transports collectifs
et donc ça pousse aussi les villes aller
chercher d'autres financements chercher
d'autres financements faire des
économies c'est aussi un choix politique
un choix que conteste la puissante
fédération des usagers des transports
la fnaut qui préfèrent les tarifs
sociaux à la gratuité vraiment
encourager les gens qui peuvent
bénéficier de tarification sociale en
profiter et donc les informer mais ça ne
légitime pas le fait que les gens qui
ont les moyens de payer leur autobus ne
paye pas or on a besoin d'eux des
ressources des gens qui peuvent payer
leur bus pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
par souci d'équité entre les entreprises
et les contribuables
depuis 30 ans le financement est sûre ce
sera trois pieds si vous supprimez un
pied c'est à dire les usagers s'il ne
paye plus fort à parier que les
contribuables et les entreprises d'iran
est pourquoi nous on doit payer pour les
usages
[Musique]
garder des tarifs sociaux une fausse
bonne idée selon guillaume gontard
sénateur de l'isère et rapporteur d'une
étude sur le sujet il ya des démarches
c'est à dire faut quand même une carte
il faut quand même se se déclarer quand
même comme quoi on est plutôt défavorisé
donc ça aussi c'est un marqueur et puis
surtout ce qu'on s'est aperçu c'est que
cette population là bas même si c'est un
abonnement par mois qui est très faible
il faut quand même sortir de l'argent
par mois est en fait souvent ne font pas
ce choix là et donc du coup vont plutôt
aller soit avec des tickets à l'unité
soit fraudé et donc en fait on
s'aperçoit que c'est eux qui payent au
bout du compte plus cher le transport
que que d'autres que d'autres personnes
donc c'est un peu la limite de la
tarification de la tarification sociale
alors même s'il ya une communication qui
peut être fait autour la la gratuité ça
pose pas de questions il n'y a pas de
discrimination pour autant le rapport du
sénat sur le transport urbain gratuit ne
prend aucune position et se termine par
cette conclusion ambiguë la gratuité est
intéressante mais ce n'est pas une fin
en soi
quelques dizaines de kilomètres au nord
de châteauroux la petite commune
d'issoudun a fait le choix de la
gratuité il y a trente ans d'abord
observateurs les villages environnants
ont adhéré au concept est aujourd'hui un
bus assurent deux fois par semaine la
liaison entre la campagne et la ville
le mercredi et le samedi et un car
gratuit qui nous emmène à issoudun
en quoi ça vous rend service moi ça me
rend service parce que des juges est
prêt de voitures
donc si je peux pas prendre l'autocar
hausse il n'y a pas de te car le jour où
on aura pu et je posterai chez moi ou
alors je sais je sais pas comment je
pourrais vivre c'est quoi on peut y
aller gratuitement on peut y aller
les jours ce qui est bien le mercredi
parce que ben on n'a pas cours et ça
nous permet de pouvoir rentrer chez nous
après d'y aller donc c'est là pas besoin
de faire déplacer nos parents qui
travaillent
[Musique]
désenclaver des zones rurales qui sont
qui peuvent l'être de plus en plus tout
ce qui te créer du lien le lien entre
les communes le lien avec la ville
centre est importante car vos programmes
culturels qui a des équipements sportifs
intéressants fait bénéficier un maximum
de communes rurales et avec ce transport
là ont contribué à ce que les personnes
habitant ces communes rurales puissent
bénéficier de ces équipements ou de ceux
de cette offre culturelle renseignements
aussi donc c'est
c'est quelque chose de vraiment très
bien aujourd'hui onze villages sont
desservies par ce transport gratuit le
coût réel du billet est de 8 euros 40 un
véritable engagement pour le maire le
socialiste andré laignel vice président
des maires de france qui y voient une
réponse à la crise des territoires ceux
qui sont sans moyens de déplacement les
appels des captifs et moi je voulais pas
qu être captif fait dans ma ville et
aujourd'hui on a des résultats tout à
fait positif puisque pour le rural
on va atteindre les 10 mille passagers
et pour la ville les 25000 c'est tout à
fait considérable
c'est aussi bien entendu des raisons
économiques
beaucoup des gens qui sont captifs sont
aussi des gens qui ont des bas revenus
soit ce sont des jeunes soit ce sont des
anciens et ils ont besoin de pouvoir se
déplacer et si possible sans que sa
grève leur maigre budget c'est un vrai
choix politique d'investissement dans le
transport collectif
ceci étant on s'aperçoit qu'il n'y a pas
de couleur politique autour de cette
mesure on a autant des maires de droite
de gauche de centre gauche de
centre-droit des écologistes qui ont été
convaincues des communistes en aussi
qu'ils ont été convaincus par cette ce
type de mesures est d'ailleurs on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya plutôt une assez
grande équité entre ces différentes
formations politiques dans les 35 villes
du transport gratuit
à châteaudun petite ville de 13 mille
habitants la gratuité des transports a
été décidée en 2009 par le maire
socialiste est conservé par son
successeur de droite qui était pourtant
opposés par principe je ne suis pas
spontanément fera la gratuité des
services publics c'est à dire que la
collectivité des habitants payent pour
une partie d'usagé mais là ça dépasse
sur l'a7 gratuite et elle a cette
particularité de répondre à un autre
besoin qui lui est tout à fait d'intérêt
général les plus gratuit à soit 1 je
trouve ça très très bien pour les jeunes
qui n'ont pas forcément les moyens de
payer les transports en commun comme par
exemple à chartres on est obligé de
payer un heureux 30 le bus pour aller à
l'hôpital où faire ses courses alors que
même par exemple pour des personnes
âgées ou des personnes malades
moi je trouve ça assez cher 1 euros 30
quand je suis arrivé ici je n'avais pas
l'habitude de voir des l'usd et gratuit
totalement gratuit j'ai pris le bus
allait connaître l'ensemble parce que
son appartenance et bien l'écart d'une
loi qui assure les transports sont une
filiale de la ratp de bus desservent
toutes les heures 28 arrêts sur deux
circuits différents
il vous sert à quoi ce tous gratuits
plot
on va les faire
des agents au pays
[Musique]
tous
il veut par tous
jusqu'à la finale
hier jusqu'au magasin les contrats
presse
bien en 2009 à châteaudun avant la
gratuité
le nombre de voyages dans l'année
s'élevaient à 5000 dix ans plus tard il
a plus que triplé
mais l'essentiel semble être ailleurs le
transport gratuit à une importance qui
va au delà de l'aide financière que ça
peut apporter à ceux qui en bénéficient
c'est une chose de mixité de la
participation citoyenne à lens un grand
mot mais c'est que chaque habitant se
sente chez lui partout dans la ville
direction le nord
l'agglomération de dunkerque et ses deux
cent mille habitants
[Musique]
depuis deux ans la patrie du célèbre
corsaire jean bart possède le plus grand
réseau français de transport gratuit une
révolution pour le délégataire de
service keolis qui a conduit ce
bouleversement
ah bah nous on a tout changé donc c'est
pas compliqué on a changé la couleur des
bus on a acheté enfin la communauté
urbaine à acheter de nouveaux véhicules
en hachant et la tenue des conducteurs
on a changé nos organisations du travail
on a changé notre manière d'accueillir
les clients puisque et puis de tickets à
vendre ou à vérifier donc on a changé
finalement tous nos process et puis dans
la nuit du 31 août au 1er septembre 2018
une entreprise 9 s'est réveillé et a mis
en route le nouveau réseau il y a deux
ans 67 % des déplacements se faisait en
voiture et la billetterie représentait
seulement 10% des recettes
aujourd'hui la fréquentation des bus a
explosé + 65 % en semaine et plus 125%
le week end
l'artisan de ce succès c'est lui patrice
vergriete ancien urbanistes élus en 2014
maire de dunkerque sur cette promesse de
gratuité bien avant la crise des gilet
jaune
le nordiste est sans doute le meilleur
porte parole de la gratuité des
transports urbains en france la
situation était un peu catastrophique à
dunkerque
d'abord parce que ici on est une ville
reconstruite après la seconde guerre
mondiale vous connaissez le film de
christopher nolan est donc une ville qui
a été construite pour la voiture et donc
la voiture était ultra dominante dans
les modes de déplacement sauf que la
voiture coûte cher elles polluent et
dans une voie dans une ville faite pour
la voiture les problématiques
d'exclusion évidemment plus nombreuses
puisque quand vous n'avez pas de voiture
vous êtes davantage exclu le bus
gratuits à dunkerque c'est aussi une
super vitrine pour la ville
le bus gratuit ça hamid hakkar sur le
devant de la scène ce spot même
européenne je pense que c'est je pense
qu'il ya eu des des villes les gens de
villes allemandes sacs sont venus voir
la gratuité au départ quand ça a été
lancé son nul voir tout ça puis façon
maintenant on parle que d'écologie donc
je pense que limiter le nombre de
véhicules à particuliers en dans les
centre-villes c'est l'avenir
l'avenir c'est aussi un véhicule penser
différemment avec des animations et même
des bornes de jeux pour les jeunes je ne
prenais pas avant mais maintenant je
prends tout le temps parce que grande
facilité pour se ranger de personnel
monde le frein jusqu'à dunkerque en 17
minutes on est au centre-ville
c'est beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas
cette place pour se garer
parfait c'est formidable ma voiture je
n'utilise plus on laisse au parking et
puis très sympathique le genre son
stress à pas formulant ça se passe bien
24% des usagers qu'on a rencontrés dans
le bus sur deux mille usagers nous ont
affirmé qu'ils avaient laissé leur
automobile pour prendre le bus pour
prendre le transport collectif
donc c'est quand même significatif à
dunkerque mais ça ne veut pas dire que
ce changement de comportement se
retrouva dans d'autres villes parce que
dunkerque a eu un projet vraiment global
de reconfiguration des mobilités
et du côté des conducteurs on apprécie
de ne plus avoir d'argent à manipuler
si la libération sincèrement je pense
que pour tous mes collègues aussi c'est
une grande libération depuis avoir de
ticket à a donné d'argent à recevoir à
rendre voilà et puis plus d'argent dire
à risque de l'agression en moins voyez
pas ce qu'il ya des gens pour une pièce
ils m'ont agressé on se préoccupe pas de
200 je viens il n'y a pas d'argent donc
on sait qu'on est sera on est serein
parmi les opposants à la gratuité il ya
aussi le gart
le puissant lobby des autorités
responsables du transport qui estiment
que c'est plutôt la multiplication des
bus qui fait le succès de la formule
on voit bien que la plupart de ceux qui
ont augmenté véritablement la
fréquentation en même temps que la
gratuité
ils ont augmenté l'offre c'est le cas de
dunkerque
il a mis plus d'argent pour augmenter
l'offre que le montant des gratuités
qu'il a économisées qu'il a en fait
voilà donc y avait quatre millions de
recettes
il a dépensé 12 millions 5 pour
augmenter l'offre on voit bien que si on
n'augmente pas l'offre la gratuité c'est
un coup d'épée dans l'eau
ici comme ailleurs la gratuité n'est pas
gratuite
les usagers sont les premiers à se poser
la question du financement
non mais c'est magnifique c'est un bon
geste le savoir si ça va durer dans le
temps
je dirais pas ça va ça représente quand
même une certaine une certaine somme
d'argent ce constat
il ya un seul désavantage le coût des
camondo des il faut compenser le coût
tout à l'heure je vous ai dit ça a coûté
16 millions d'euros en plus à la
collectivité donc c'est réel c'est une
vraie dépense donc oui j'ai eu un
engagement politique 16 millions d'euros
par exemple aujourd'hui à dunkerque on
n'a pas d'aréna
on aurait pu avoir une aréna de 10000
places on a fait un choix c'est d'avoir
le bus gratuit donc non ça a un coût
donc il y à bien un désavantage mais n'y
en a qu'un dunkerque son carnaval son
usine arcelormittal et maintenant ces
bus gratuit on pourrait en sourire
mais ici aussi quelque chose a changé
qui n'est pas mesurable
moi j'ai beaucoup de naguère crois
qu'ils me parlent de la gratuité pas
simplement pour le pouvoir d'achat
pas simplement pour la lutte contre
l'exclusion mais pour la convivialité
ils me disent ben écoute avant je
prenais la voiture finalement c'était
pas si agréable que ça j'avais des
difficultés à me garer et où puis
j'étais dans ma voiture seule
aujourd'hui je fais des rencontres j'ai
des amis des copains debussy et la
notion de copains de bus qui est apparue
depuis qu'on a la gratuité ici et
finalement ils découvrent une autre
façon de vivre et de se déplacer qu'ils
découvrent positif et c'est ça qui
finalement c'est là qu'on voit que le
pari est gagné
jusqu'à présent la gratuité des
transports ne concernait que les villes
depuis le 1er mars le luxembourg est
devenu le premier pays au monde où l'on
peut prendre le train le tram ou le bus
sans payer
ce petit pays de 620 mille habitants
n'est pas seulement l'un de ceux où le
niveau de vie est l'un des plus élevés
ou le siège de grandes institutions
internationales
il est aussi celui qui veut donner une
leçon d'écologie au reste du monde
regardez les agglomérations partout en
europe sont asphyxiés
ça ne marche plus ça ne fonctionne plus
c'est à dire que je crois que c'est
vraiment c'est un terrain très important
pour tous ceux qui s'engagent en
écologie de vraiment voir ces liens
entre les transports il meilleure façon
d'organiser la mobilité et la création
écologie 47 % des déplacements
professionnels se font en voiture contre
32% seulement pour le bus et les
bouchons sont légendaires la gratuité
devrait faire économiser en moyenne 100
euros par an à chaque foyer et
bénéficiera aussi aux deux cent mille
travailleurs transfrontaliers dont cent
mille français je peut épargner de
l'argent bien sûr parce que je vais
recommencer le travail
à la femme et moi et
c'est bon pour moi je peux
acheter des cadeaux pour mes enfants le
fait d'avoir des transports gratuits ça
permet vraiment pas d'avoir une très
grande mobilité dans le pays qu'ils
soient grands ou petits
mais en plus ça permet de soin
d'investir dans des choses qui nous font
plaisir soit vraiment de pouvoir
économiser sur des choses plus
importantes de personnes qui a le
transport gratuit et on prendra le
transport plutôt que mettre de l'essence
ou les jours je pense que ça sera plutôt
la facilité mais pour les écologistes
luxembourgeois l'amélioration de l'offre
est plus importante que la gratuité
l'offre n'est plus adéquat durant les 30
prochaines années la population
luxembourgeoise a augmenté de 80%
comment voulez-vous résoudre ce problème
maintenant les transports en commun ne
sont plus adaptées aux besoins comment
l'assurer qu'il le soit même si on les
développe avec une telle croissance
ça ne fonctionne prêts et les prix
gratuit ne vont rien changer aux
questions fondamentales
le modèle luxembourgeois est il
transposable
certains en doutent si tous les états
est tout aussi riche que le luxembourg
on pourrait effectivement se payer pas
la solidarité publique et par l'impôt la
gratuité des services publics on a
aujourd'hui une conjoncture financière
qui est calamiteuse pour nos
collectivités locales et on n'est pas le
luxembourg le luxembourg est un pays
avec un trait au produit intérieur brut
c'est à dire riche mais d'un autre côté
c'est aussi une question de priorisation
de la politique parce que quand vous
regardez le luxembourg actuellement
investi 600 euros par tête habitants par
an dont l'extension du réseau
ferroviaire en france on est aux
alentours de 42 euros c'est-à-dire
luxembourg n'est quand même dit pas 10
fois plus riche que la france c'est une
question de priorité il faut changer
vraiment renverser les priorités
c'est-à-dire peut-être à investir moulin
dans l'extension du réseau routier est
plus dans l'extension du réseau
ferroviaire
le luxembourg sera t'il l'exemple à
suivre
il est un peu tôt pour le dire mais
changer la mobilité n'est pas seulement
changé la façon de se déplacer on peut
espérer en tout cas c'est qu'ils aient
plus de déplacements transports
collectifs et en vélo c'est à dire des
modes de transport décarbonés par
rapport à l'automobile
et parce que ces modes de transport
permettent de reconfigurer les villes
c'est ça qui est intéressant même si on
va passer à la voiture électrique la
voiture électrique ne va pas permettre
finalement de transformer la
convivialité dans la ville et donc
j'imagine peut-être une convivialité
meilleur grâce à des transports
collectifs et conviviaux dans les
grandes villes
[Musique]
si on est trop coercitif si on est dans
l'écologie punitive
quelque part on va décourager la
population d'aller vers ce monde du 21e
siècle qui correspond à quelque chose
qui est cohérent avec l'enjeu
environnemental
on sait donc que politiquement il faut
donner envie à la population d'un
nouveau monde de nouveaux comportements
et donc il faut des incitations il faut
des projets nouveaux et innovants qui
produisent un choc psychologique quelque
part dans la population pour donner
envie du monde de demain
je suis persuadé que l'imminente
l'humanité n'a pas d'autre choix que de
changer de système dont la mobilité au
xxème siècle parce que sinon vous allez
droit dans le mur on est déjà
aujourd'hui partout à saturation totale
avec le système et nous on peut servir
comme laboratoire comme vraiment base
d'idées qui peut à la fin être
implémentée par tous
la mobilité telle qu'elle est organisée
aujourd'hui est un échec avec des
embouteillages dans les villes et des
zones périphériques délaissé la crise
sanitaire qui secoue le monde ne fait
que renforcer l'urgence de repenser nos
déplacements
[Applaudissements]